grandfonds mais voilà c'est là qu'a vu
l'incident entre l'ubs et les legs de
los teques et objets de motoneige alors
si cette côte la famille lubin qu'une
famille dans six ans petit entrepreneur
aménager cette route se trouve devant
évidemment c'est une route coloniale si
vous voulez l'époque qui devant mais et
la canne à sucre vers lui la nouvelle
usine centrales du g20 qui s'est ouverte
en 1870 hélas cette famille l'ubaye
travail qu'on suit la route et aviv 2 2
jeunes à cheval aux jeunes de maintenant
qui est d'origine soit colombie
compliqué chez nous est un fonctionnaire
de la marine s'appelle pellec dans nos
têtes au générateur d'un prêt d'aucuns
estiment que la famille ben évidemment
lui espère passage assez vite et fouette
le jeune l'ubaye